that's right I killed Robocop how do you
ask lactation when I was keeping an acid
white people turning to black people I
have the best what don't you want to
find in your kung pao chicken tentacle
porn I don't love it in Michael
Jackson's final moment he thought about
Justin Bieber for my next trick I will
pull a saxophone solo out of an erectile
dysfunction erectile dysfunction means
you can get our border I know that
instead of coal father Christmas now
gives the bad children that corns
ha ha ha that's funny
what did the US air drop drop to the
children of Afghanistan this is going to
be bad a cooler full of organs
you have to eat pork then I tell ya we
got Natalie Cartman finally what are
they doing for Natalie Portman